people want to know how to stop the
laziness and they want to know how to
stop the procrastination and you know
they have some idea in their head
you know some kind of a vision what they
want to do but they don't know where to
start in order to start it you know they
don't know where to start and say they
say hey where do I start
and and when's the best time to start
and I have a very simple answer for that
here and now that's it you you want to
improve you want to get better you want
to get on a workout program or a clean
diet you want to start a business you
want to write a book or make a movie or
build a house or a computer or put
together some mobile application where
do you start you start right here and
when do you start you start right now
you initiate the action aggressively you
go because the idea isn't going to
execute itself and the book isn't going
to write itself and the weights out in
the gym
they're not going to move themselves you
have to do it and you have to do it now
and that means you got to stop thinking
about it and stop dreaming about it and
stop researching every aspect of it and
reading all about it and debating the
pros and cons of it just start doing it
take that first step and make it happen
get after it get after it
here and now